voilà c'est le dernier clip de george
michael alors ce que je veux dire en
montrant sa c'est finalement maintenant
voilà quoi avant on se souvient dans le
temps quand les chanteurs étaient au
monsieur je ne disais pas c'était secret
ça se raconte et maintenant voilà et on
la trappe dans les toilettes et il fait
un clip pour dire oui je suis homosexuel
donc est ce que vous pensez pas par
rapport à sa copine moi c'est quelque
chose qui est passé dans les moeurs pour
qu'on n'y peut pas grand chose
finalement que je ne crois pas que ce
soit complètement passées dans les
moeurs je pense que il y a encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire pour que ça
passe dans les moeurs
du reste vous vous donnez l'exemple d'un
chanteur mais moi j'entends dans le
monde politique
beaucoup des personnes de la communauté
homosexuelle reproche que les hommes
politiques où paraît-il il ya beaucoup
d'homosexuels par utile
il y en a très peu qui affirment qu'ils
osent affirmer et regardez par exemple
monsieur labarrère qui me l'a dit depuis
fort longtemps et tout à fait
respectable et admirable également à
celle de la pause personnellement aucun
problème lorsqu'il faut dire c'est quand
même qu'il ya très peu de gens en tout
cas en france qui le disent qu'ils l'ont
dit et on peut le comprendre on n'a pas
les blâmer je trouve affreux d'ailleurs
qu'on fasse ce qu'on appelle je crois de
de la outings cela fonctionne on dénonce
4 c'est un choix c'est à chacun de dire
ce qu'il a envie de le dire mais il faut
surtout préciser que c'est beaucoup plus
facile à dire quand on est un peu connus
ou célèbres comme la haine george
michael est évidemment que de fait
partie de la bonne bourgeoisie
bordelaise pas exactement son entourage
ne permettrait probablement pas que la
personne n'y a pas chez l'avant choisi
parce que bon on ne laisse pas les
messieurs dans les milieux populaires ce
n'est pas non plus une chose que l'on
dit facile
non on disait que je dis à 20 minutes
c'est quand même beaucoup plus compliqué
pour quelqu un petit bonheur dans une
usine d'exprimer sa hlm en face à son
entourage que par rapport à un chanteur
à succès acquis toute façon sera protégé
par sa notoriété
je vais vous dire quand vous grandissez
la bible quand vous grandissez la bible
la ville st faire mal comme la bible
c'est des sodomites il ya beaucoup il ya
sur des mégots mort il ya de l'inceste
quand la fille aînée de lot torche son
père pour qu'il la saute c'est dans la
vie la vie du gnl 19 génèse mais je
préfère le prince d'égypte moi je salue
tout ça absolument pas je suis pas là
vous avez la fille de lot à fille aînée
de lot fait boire son père et son père
lui fait un enfant est prêt à
recommencer les casseurs salomon
polygamie 1000 femmes
les maris marié à 12 ans parce que je
veux dire c'est que les comportements
humains qui sont rapportés dans la bible
mais en ce qui concerne la bim
je peux malheureusement moi je n'ai pas
préparé comme vous et je ne ne peux pas
vous donner la prime est mâché victimes
et mons umons à quai dans la loge unie
mais suis désolé mais on février me
chercher on dira que la bible et dans
mon sac à ce moment là je voudrais la
référence exacte c'est à la fois
d'anciens dire nouveau testament est
effectivement dit très clairement que
l'homosexualité n'est pas acceptable
oui enfin là c'est la polygamie tout ça
c'est de la non intégration
le problème n'est pas celui là vous
m'aviez posé la question de savoir
pourquoi j'avais montré cette bible et
bien j'avais mangé montrer cette ville
parce que c'est l ouvrage que j'avais
dans mon sac
madame guigou pour gagner du temps nous
lisez pas une deuxième fois lundi soir
qu'elle nous avait eu une heure plus tôt
donc moi j'essayais de lui donner
d'autres sujets de lecture et on n'en a
pas voulu
mais par contre monsieur h députés
communistes a lutté a lu la bible
cantique des cantiques et l'ecclesia ça
choque personne
voilà c'était communiste tout le monde
trouve ça normal voilà les premières à
la fête de l'humanité la prochaine fois
vous savez qu'elle t'a mêlera jésus on
trouve ça tout à fait normal
personne ne dit rien mais si vous tendez
quelque chose parce que l'état
catholique parce qu'elle est catholique
pardonnez moi et bien à ce moment là ça
devient objet de scandale
c'est absolument fait staline avec de
vigne mais moi je suis pas sa ligne 1
alors moi je me demande au fond je me
dire pourquoi vous a demandé de déplacer
soit parce qu'on a parlé du consensus
sont apparus du politiquement correct on
va parler de la provocation se demandant
où est passée la provocation
moi je me demande au fond si vous n'êtes
pas la dernière provocatrice parce que
finalement aujourd'hui tout le monde
pense à peu près la même chose et vous
arrivez à l'assemblée nationale ont pris
la parole vous est alors vite encore
plus provocatrice que salle vous
connaissez ce journal ça que je viens
vous avez donné c'est comme la
provocation ça dans un journal s'appelle
tabloïds qui est un journal gai delà de
la région
je reçoive attention venus à temps c'est
la région rhône alpes le journal gai de
la région de la région rhône alpes il ya
un article qui est en page 6 jeudi sa
patricia voilà qui s'appelle christine
boutin j'aime le sexe mois jura contre
ça moi aussi j'adore le texte non mais
voilà je montre à la caméra
donc je suis pas est ce que vous vous
êtes une provocatrice tu sais pas non
mais je sont vos paroles vous en bien
j'ai les miennes a regardé m'engage
également
et quand j'ai accepté de faire 2 1 une
interview dans cette revue gay je les
fais parce que je n'ai pas de raison de
ne pas répondre à une demande d'une
revue gay pour préparer le pacs j'ai
rencontré la communauté homosexuelle
ce que j'ai dit c'est pas simplement
dans mon idée de l'idéologie de
l'idéologie de dogmatisme
j'essaie d'être compétent des personnes
homosexuelles me demande une interview
je réponds alors ce que j'ai essayé de
leur faire comprendre c'est que j'aime
et l'amour bien sûr et donc ça a été
titré j'aime le sexe bien c'est pas mal
merci ben voilà donc maintenant on va
passer ses invités à dîner mais mme
boutin sur l'interface que j'ai offert
un bouquet de fleurs c'était toi comme
ça se passe et elle va être sûrement
pleurer pendant la mission
et c'est pas mal c'était délicieux
mettait des larmes c'était des larmes de
crocodile a été profondément blessée est
vrai absolument j'estime que le premier
ministre est la question que vous lui
posez en décembre du mal à vous croire
pousse à vous c'est votre responsabilité
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que j'ai
été blessé et je voulais demander au
premier ministre si véritablement
c'était sa façon de traiter les femmes
ce qu'il venait de faire devant
l'ensemble de la classe pu arrêter d'un
mois les affaires mais vous savez bien
que non bon annoncer très bien vous
aviez juste pas être un des premiers
bilans
c'est un nom même si c'est maintenant la
possibilité à vous vous savez très bien
que qu'il a très bien quand même le
premier à avoir commencé à faire rentrer
les femmes la balle et enfin ce n'est
pas je suis pas béni oui oui on est très
en deçà de ce qu'il faudrait c'est
beaucoup d'efforts je suis assis les
mêmes sous jospin que jamais il est par
ailleurs encore beaucoup d'émoi la
palestine vise à répondre à dire tous
mais justement à paris et quand on voit
comment serait d'une femme de tous les
côtés des questions on va avancer je
suis désolé donc on passe au débat donc
on appelle toc chaude il le dire quelque
chose encore karine mathieu encore une
chose je sais pas vous le dites que le
premier ministre que les idées de
manière dont on traite un député moi il
me semble en tout cas qu'un certain
nombre de vos collègues députés ont une
curieuse manière de traiter les femmes
dans l'hémicycle et ça malheureusement
ça se voit très souvent la télévision
qui fait très bien
je suis inquiet jeudi pour collègues ses
collègues à jedwabne collègues dans
l'autre monde
contrairement à ce que beaucoup de
femmes disent je dis qu'il est très
agréable est une femme en politique
parce que les absents pour toi bien
alors soit c'est celle là on passe alors
on passe vraiment en débat donc ça
s'appelle talk show